so we've spent plenty of time in recent
weeks discussing the horrific unethical
dangerous and barbaric practices of many
hospitals and children's hospitals
around the country all being performed
under the guise of gender affirmation
now the media has frantically insisted
that we have to stop scrutinizing the
medical establishment in this way even
if hospitals are sterilizing and
butchering children the media says we
must not uh we must not offer any
critique because if we do we're guilty
of incitement and even terrorism
so we have to remain silent they tell us
but I've never personally been very good
at following orders especially when
those orders are delivered by the
soulless goblins in the National media
I'm much more inclined to do exactly the
opposite of whatever they say and in
fact all this talk about the
Frankenstein Butchery happening in our
nation's hospitals has made us wonder
about the hospital closest to us here in
Nashville uh Vanderbilt Vanderbilt
University Medical Center is the full
name Vanderbilt we'll just call it for
short over the past several days we have
investigated uh the matter
and now I want to show you what we found
and let's begin
at the beginning as we tell this story
so in 2018
Vanderbilt opened its transgender Health
Center there was an article published in
The Tennessean at the time that
announced the new Clinic quoting its
medical director Dr Shane Taylor who
said that the goal was to quote meet our
patients where they are in their journey
and help them with the resources they
need
but then in a lecture during
Vanderbilt's lgbtq Health Grand rounds
lecture series which live streamed to
Facebook but was viewed by almost nobody
at the time Dr Taylor was a bit more
detailed in explaining the hospital's
actual motivations for expanding into
quote-unquote transgender care in fact
she said that she personally helped to
convince the institution to make the
move based in part because she claims
it's the right thing to do but also in
large part because gender affirmation
surgeries are quote big money makers she
boasted that a phalloplasty which is the
construction of an artificial penis
which is made using flesh cut from other
parts of the body she said those could
be worth a hundred thousand dollars when
you factor in all of the follow-ups that
are necessary listen
starting in January 1st of 2017
according to the Affordable Care Act
insurance cover carriers are mandated to
cover medical expenses for Trans folks
um some of our UMC Financial folks in 20
in August of 20 I'm sorry October of
2016 sorry a couple years ago put down
some costs of how much money we think
each patient would bring in and this is
only including Top surgery this doesn't
include any bottom surgery and
um it's a lot of money these surgeries
make a lot of money so female to male
and chest reconstruction can bring in
forty thousand dollars a patient just on
routine hormone treatment who I'm only
seeing a few times a year can bring in
several thousand dollars that requires a
lot of business and Labs it actually
makes money for the hospital
now these I got from the internet
um but it's from the Philadelphia Center
for transgender surgery which has um
does a lot of surgery for patients and I
just want to give you an idea of how
much these bottom surgeries are making
and this is I think this has to be an
underestimate this is for vaginoplasty
they're saying they're quoting roughly
around twenty thousand dollars for
imagine a costume but that doesn't
include your hospital stay that doesn't
include your post-op visits that doesn't
include
um your anesthesia your or so I would
think that this has to be a gross
underestimate I think that's just like
the surgeons piece of it which anybody
who's ever been in the hospital knows
that that's like
uh and the female's male bottom
surgeries these are huge money makers
again I think this has to be an
underestimate that they're voting around
twenty thousand dollars for a
phalloplasty there's been different
things that I've read that said it could
be up to a hundred thousand dollars
um Dr lineker who's our surgeon says
that there's entire clinics where the
entire Clinic is supported just by their
falloplasties and that is like a
fraction of the surgeries that they're
doing these surgeries are
labor-intensive they require a lot of
follow-ups they require a lot of or time
and they make money they make money from
the hospital
now profitable though may be there are
some medical professionals who take the
Hippocratic Oath seriously and object to
carving up a person's body in this way
Vanderbilt was apparently concerned that
some of their own staff might fall into
that category so at another grand rounds
lecture in 2019 a woman named Dr Ellen
Clayton who's a pediatric specialist at
Vanderbilt told those assembled that if
they refuse to participate due to their
religious beliefs in these procedures
there will be consequences conscientious
objections are problematic she explained
and those who object really shouldn't
work at Vanderbilt at all listen
if you were going to assert
conscientious objection
you have to realize that that is
problematic
you are doing something to another
person
and you are not paying for the cost for
your belief
I think that is a real I mean I think
that's a real issue so
um
so I think you know so you're so yes
Vanderbilt if someone has a country to
the objections for participating in this
sort of surgery
if it would probably have to accommodate
you to the extent that you can find
another person who can do your job who
doesn't have an objection other things
of that nature but I just want you to
take home
that say that you're not going to do
something because if you're a
conscientious citizen because of your
religious beliefs is not without
consequences
and
I just want to put that out there we are
given enormous if you don't want to do
this kind of work don't work at
Vanderbilt
now is it legal to make those kinds of
threats I mean can she legally promise
consequences for those who exercise
their first amendment rights
well whether she can legally do that or
not she did and the point was made clear
Vanderbilt just got into the gender
transition game and now it is such a
central part of its core Mission and its
business plan that any Doctor Who
objects is not welcome to work in the
hospital at all
yet even with These Warnings Vanderbilt
is is uh would seem to be deeply
concerned that some of the doctors on
their staff
might still
stick to their bigoted superstitions
like you know their belief in human
biology and that sort of thing so to
solve that problem they proudly unveiled
a first in the nation they say program
called trans buddy well if you are like
so many people in our culture uh
desperate for validation and respect
then I've got one way you can achieve
that uh it's with established titles now
established titles is your opportunity
to earn the title of Lord or lady and
gain the respect that you deserve all
you need is a one square foot plot of
land in Scotland it's all takes in your
title pack you'll be bestowed with at
least one square foot of dedicated land
on a private estate in edelston Scotland
plus an official certificate with a
Crest as you can see I have mine here
which I usually proudly display uh in my
studio ear certificate features a unique
plot Number with uh which you can see
the exact location of your land and you
can even go and I guess probably stand
on it if you want to title packs from
established titles are a fun and unique
gift for any occasion and there are even
couple packs that come with adjoining
plots of land for the special someone in
your life with your certificate you
could officially add the prefix of Lord
or lady to your credit card to your
plane tickets even your dating profiles
most importantly and get this
house titles told me that the first 200
people purchasing a title pack using my
exclusive link will receive a plot
within a few walking minutes of mine so
depending on how many of us become Lords
and Ladies we can build our own kingdom
established titles is actually running a
massive sale right now plus if you use
the code wall should get an additional
10 off so it's a lot of incentive all
you got to do is go to
establishtitles.com Walsh to get your
gifts now and help support the channel
so the trans buddy program means that
trans patients are paired up with an
activist from the community who attends
appointments with them
the trans buddy initiative is is there
to quote observe how Hospital staff are
interacting
and to ensure that they're using correct
pronouns a trans buddy volunteer in the
clip will play for you in a second even
explains that some medical providers at
Vanderbilt are unsafe and so they
require this form of a babysitting watch
my name is Sean Riley and I am the
program coordinator for Trans buddy at
the program for lgbtq health at
Vanderbilt University
transbuddy provides trained peer
advocates for transgender patients who
are coming for doctors appointments or
other healthcare related Services
whether you're looking for something
that's really it's a medical transition
such as hormone therapy or something
completely unrelated like breaking an
arm or going to an ENT we are here here
to help support any transgender patients
that come through our doors
foreign
the transmitting program was organically
created through the efforts of
transgender people and continues to
consistently be led by trans people in
Middle Tennessee transporting program is
a one of a kind in the nation and
institutions are looking to Vanderbilt
to replicate and expand programs like
ours we are not seeking to find
Solutions often for people's problems
we're just seeking to be there and to
accompany and to be a friendly face
and to be a non-medical face in a in a
place where everybody coming in the room
is going to be a healthcare provider and
and may be unsafe sometimes I'm there to
be um sort of always observing kind of
how Hospital staff are interacting with
individuals and again you know using
correct pronouns or treating the
individual with respect
so this is less a buddy program than a
Big Brother program though of course
they would never use such a gendered
term and we did check and confirm that
Vanderbilt makes their orwellian trans
buddies available to patients of any age
including minors
in fact a trans buddy may help Shepherd
a child through many types of services
all provided by the hospital's pediatric
gender Clinic Vanderbilt administers
chemical castration drugs AKA puberty
blockers and irreversible hormone
therapy to minors though sometime in the
last month or two interestingly enough
they removed language from their website
explicitly advertising this practice we
had to look it up on the archived
version of the website we found it there
but not the current version
yet they may have forgotten to delete a
video from Vanderbilt psychiatry's
YouTube channel back in 2020 which
admits explicitly that they will give
and have given irreversible hormone
drugs to children as young as 13. listen
we can provide gender affirming hormones
on an individual who is on a pubertal
blocker depending on whatever kind of
blocker they've chosen or we have
discussed with them or they can present
to us at a later stage of puberty and
then we provide the gender affirming
hormones previously the endocrine
Society recommended to start these at
age 16 but we all know that would be
delayed puberty right not 16 year olds
don't start puberty so more recently
they did update that to say as early as
14 for compelling reasons so we have
some individuals who have started gender
affirming hormones at 13 or 14 to be
more like their peers again fertility
preservation and consent are very
important to discuss prior to any
initiation
for compelling reasons and I think we
can probably assume that uh they've
never met a reason that was not
compelling to them so after they've
drugged and sterilized the kids
Vanderbilt as explained in this video
presentation by plastic surgeon Julian
winacore and physicians assistant
Shaylin Van Der blowman at that point
they will happily perform double
mastectomies on adolescent girls
so when we when we talk about the wpath
guidelines so in order for our patients
to really successfully undergo these
surgeries we do uh again follow these
guidelines so a lot of times it's for
insurance purposes but again
insurance is kind of follow suit with
the wpath guidelines for the most part
so for any kind of Top surgery uh we do
require one letter of persistent
well-documented gender dysphoria by a
licensed mental health provider
um we ensure that the patient is capable
of making a fully informed decisions on
their own they're the age of majority
however for a lot of our younger
patients again if they are 16 17 here at
Vanderbilt if they have been on
testosterone have a parental consent
we're able to do a lot of the top
surgeries for those patients
so
let's review Vanderbilt got into the
gender transition transition game
admittedly in large part because it's
very financially profitable and it is
they then threatened any staff members
who objected and then enlisted a gang of
trans activists to act as surveillance
in order to force compliance and they
now castrate sterilize and mutilate
children as well as adults while
apparently taking steps to hide this
activity from the public view which is
why we had to sift through web archives
and track down videos not available to
the general public just to confirm all
of this information
we're left in the end once again with a
stark reality that the field of medicine
has been infiltrated and co-opted by
Radical ideologues by left-wing cultists
and LGBT extremists Vanderbilt like so
many other medical institutions has
sacrificed both science and ethics on
the altar of gender ideology
and we who object are labeled terrorists
but that is the desperate tactic of a
system that knows it is being exposed
we can't allow ourselves to be bullied
by those kinds of intimidation tactics
and emotional blackmail
we are confronting one of the great
evils in human history there's no
question about it
and nobody said it would be easy or
painless and if they did they were lying
either way
we have to hold the line
well I hope you enjoyed that clip from
Matt wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com And subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts